- So, I feel like we very
casually brushed over the fact
that you saw a demon in this house.
- There's an older man.
He shot himself in my room.
- In your room?
- Yeah.
- I was not told that this
trip would be like this.
(laughing)
- I purposely didn't tell
you until you were here, so.
(gasps)
- Thank you.
(creepy music)
(upbeat music)
- So, we're in the car right now,
we're on our way to Casper,
Wyoming to see the eclipse.
- The moon's finally gonna defeat the sun.
(cheering)
- Go, moon, go!
- Right now, hotel rooms cost--
- 30,000 dollars!
- I asked on Twitter if I
had any fans in Wyoming.
- We're not just staying in a fan,
we're staying in a teen fan's bedroom.
- Hi.
(bright music)
- Eugene is in New York for a wedding,
Ned is also seeing the
eclipse in Portland?
- He's in Oregon,
- In Oregon.
- He's glamping.
- Glamping.
Glamping.
Still glamping.
Oh my goodness.
- Fucking Ned.
Also, very special guest joining
us on the trav-vlog today,
Becka!
- Becky!
- This is the last trip you're taking
as a not-married-couple.
- Yeah, that's right,
that's why we brought you
to keep us virgins til the wedding day.
(bright music)
♫ You're my best friend
♫ Best friend
(exhales loudly)
- God.
Oh my god, why did you scream?
- We were spitting out air because we went
through a tunnel and made wishes.
- What is wrong with you?
- Did you sleep again?
We're here, we did it, Casper.
- [Aurora] Yeah, okay.
(chuckles)
- [Zach] High five.
- Boom.
- Aurora, what are these?
- [Aurora] We made you these things!
- (gasps) It's a little pug!
- This seems super nice.
- Seems super nice.
- Alright, well here we are in our room.
- [Keith] Yeah.
- The three of us.
- Feels kinda like Room
Raiders for some reason.
- Yeah.
- [Zach] So, am I in this one?
This is my roommate.
- Here's five-pair right here.
- [Zach] Oh wow, these are the glasses.
- [Keith] Thank you so much.
- [Zach] What are you doing?
- [Aurora] (laughs) Watching
Ned's story on Insta.
- [Voice] Glamping.
- Finally made it to the top.
- They call this Monkey Rock,
I don't really see it.
Really looks like a dick from down below.
Can't even wrap my hand around it.
- [Voice] Glamp.
- [Zach] Ned?
Don't you speak his name in this house.
(screaming)
- [Zach] I'm looking at the other cat,
the cat's lookin' at
me, it's a nice moment.
- [Keith] Oh yeah, look at that.
- [Keith] What did you get?
- [Keith] That's the last of that button.
- [Keith] It's a beach ball, I think.
- A hat!
- [Keith] A winter hat.
- Are these stickers?
- [Keith] Ooh a pen!
- We have a new aspiration journal.
This is such a good haul.
This is all so cool,
thank you guys so much.
Post-its, supposed to be Post-its.
- [Keith] Office supplies
are the end of this.
- [Keith] Wow, this is
stuff you cannot buy!
(bright music)
♫ Thank you, thank you, thank you
♫ Very very very much
♫ Very much
- Broasted chicken!
- [Zach] You look great
in this purple light.
- Do I look good?
- Where's Aurora?
- She's over there, she's
looking at the spider.
- Aurora told me that there is a dead
little girl that lives in a room.
- Wait, I'm sorry, what?
- Named Emily, who died of polio.
- Wait, what?
- That is what she told me.
- I'm sorry, hey Aurora,
can you come here for a second please?
Just heard a rumor, heard a rumor
that your house is haunted?
- Yeah, it's over a hundred
years old so you can expect it.
- [Caitlin] No, it's not the house.
- I don't know, I wouldn't expect that.
- It's not me!
- [Caitlin] It's her.
They stay with Aurora because she has
this really great energy around her and so
(laughing)
- She has this really great energy.
- [Zach] Frowns.
- [Caitlin] They're more attached to her
than they are to the house,
so they won't bother you.
- I'm sorry, no, we
need to tell the story,
this is a cool place to do it.
- There's an older man, he
shot himself in my room.
- What?
That's not even Emily who had Polio!
- Do you think we can get Ryan
to do some voiceover for this?
(sirens)
- I gotta say, this one
really gives me the creeps.
- It's not fun.
- No, it's not fun,
a child died.
- I'm not stoked here.
- No, I'm not stoked but everyone seems
to want to hear about it, so here we go.
- [Alex Voiceover] Built in 1912,
the house was owned by a local family.
- There was a little girl
in the family named Emily
and she died of polio, she was like four.
And I had an imaginary friend
named Emily who died when I was four so
that's pretty cool.
- I just got chills.
- [Alex Voiceover] The first
theory is that the house
is haunted by the ghost
of a previous resident,
perhaps the owners, or
even more horrifying,
the little girl, Emily.
- My door in the room they're
staying opens and closes,
I have tons of videos of it just
opening and closing by itself.
- Can you show us that?
- It's gonna fucking open.
(creepy music)
- [Shane And Ryan Voiceovers]
Oh god, no!
- Our doors do, that's a thing doors do.
- [Shane And Ryan Voiceovers]
- [Alex Voiceover] That being said,
the house has been subject to some other
strange and unexplainable phenomenon.
- [Caitlin] She has scratches on her back.
- Oh yeah, I get scratches on my back
when I'm just standing there.
(camera winding)
- [Shane And Ryan Voiceovers]
- [Alex Voiceover] Which
brings us to theory two.
Emily, is in fact, a demon.
(screeching)
and the house is not
a case of a haunting, but
instead an infestation.
(screeching)
(laughing)
- This is also the same
girl who drove around
for an entire summer with
a Ouija board in her car.
- Yeah, that's where I got the demon.
- The demon.
The demon.
- No, I was completely 100 percent awake,
it was only like midnight,
and I was in the bathroom,
and I turned around from facing the shower
and I saw a really really
tall figure wearing
one of those big hats, and
I was like, "Holy Shit."
- Did he look like
the Babadook?
- No, no! (laughs)
- I don't wanna see the Babadook.
- Did you guys get
Baba-shook in this house?
- [Alex Voiceover] That being said,
let's turn to theory three.
- You do live with cats.
- [Alex Voiceover] She
does live with cats.
(cat meowing)
Whatever the explanation,
it's clear Aurora's house
is a hotbed of activity.
But whether or not the
house is definitively
haunted will remain unsolved.
- Can one of you guys just
wheeze to complete this as a
(laughing)
- Do I have more cat fuzz on me?
Get it off of me.
- Wonder how that happened.
(cats meowing)
- I don't know, it could've
been anything Keith.
- Alright, well, let's get ready for bed.
- So, we're alone
in a teenager's bedroom.
Should we explore it?
- Yeah, let's explore it.
Is that a poster of
back-in-time Keith on the wall?
Here's Aurora's band participation
- I feel like this would
be the fake we-look-alike.
- And also, she has a good sense of humor.
- That's what our son would look like.
- I mean, I wish.
- [Keith] Oh my god.
Get off the bed.
- What do you mean?
I'm just hangin' out.
- Pop figurines.
I guess this is a Christmas present.
Stop posing sexily.
- What're you talkin' about?
I'm just.
- And we had to blur out almost all that.
Zach please.
- Hey look.
That's the Back to the Future hat.
(screaming)
(Keith laughing)
- Oh God!
- I don't even know if I got it on camera
as much as I meant to, but your scream.
(Zach screaming)
(laughing)
(Becky laughing)
(Zach screaming)
- Y'all playing with
demons I just wanna say,
hey demons, they're inviting
you, they're taunting you.
- Hey there demons, it's me, ya boy.
- I am in!
(Keith laughing)
- [Zach] Pretend you're
like the girl from the ring.
Get on the bed and crawl
like a spider lady.
- Crawl like a spider lady. (laughs)
- [Zach] She's like (growls).
- I am not your monkey, I'm a lady.
- [Zach] Clearly.
- I'm a beautiful lady.
- [Zach] Your lovely fiance.
- She's a goof (laughs).
- Gettin' married, together forever.
Can we watch Zach getting scared again?
- [Keith] Yeah.
(Zach screaming)
(Becky laughing)
- We're gettin' ready for bed.
- I got a cat on my leg,
I got a cat on the floor, and I got cats
in my heart, I'm in heaven.
- Okay, tomorrow's the eclipse
so let's eclipse our
eyes with our eyelids.
(Keith snores)
(Becky laughs)
- [Zach] So, it is the morning.
- Wow.
- [Zach] And the eclipse
has begun ever so slightly.
- It's starting.
- [Becky] It's starting.
- You can look right at the sun
without any protection at all.
You know, just a flamethrower
Just a fire-breathing horse.
Nothing to see here, let's move on.
- [Zach] Oh my god,
there's a cat on a leash.
- Things are different here.
- During the eclipse, anything can happen.
- They get powers, you get powers.
That guy you just saw,
he was a four year-old.
- [Zach] Wow, it's like a fuse.
Woah.
- The moment has arrived.
It's like a fingernail,
it's so cool you guys.
(cheering)
- Oh my god.
Bout to happen, bout to happen.
- Go moon!
Yeah!
(cheering)
- [Zach] Wow, we can't
even try to film that.
It's amazing!
- It's so pretty.
- It's the most obscene,
beautiful thing I've ever seen.
- Transcendent, incredible!
It was crazy.
- [Zach] You can't go back
to a regular moon after that.
- Yeah sun!
Take it back!
(cheering)
- Great work everybody.
- [Zach] We had a lot of
fun here in Casper, Wyoming.
- Wow, that is...
Thank you so much.
Why would a little polio girl
want to scratch your back?
(Becky growls)
- [Zach] Why do I have claws for hands?
My nipples are not that,
they're like ketchup bottles.
- [Keith] The nipples I guess are just
a part of her artistic drawing style.
- You have to remember, don't forget!
It was the most magical
thing we've ever seen,
you have to remember it forever!
- Well, that's it, we're back at home.
So, we'll see you next time on the vlog.
- Thanks for watching, it was a vlog!
- Yep.
- That's you're line, sorry.
- No, they don't even
know what's canon yet.
- [Voice] Glamping.
(cheering)
- [Voice] Dranks!
- [Man] Just get drunk
on a Monday afternoon.
- [Voice] Dranks!
- [Man] That's New York Ned,
way more attractive.
- [Voice] Dranks!
- Tall building.
Tall building.
(beep)
- Zero ghouls out of ten.
- I felt like this one
had a piece of video
evidence that was somewhat compelling.
- A door opening, sure.
- I'm a little flabbergasted
by your rating.
- Flabber-ghosted!
- Oh my god.
- Put it on a shirt!
- Don't high-five him.
- Thanks Zach.
- Maybe one ghoul without the sheet?
- Yo, what does a ghoul
look like under a sheet?
- One time, at Disneyland,
I saw the Mickey Mouse
character take his head off.
- What did he look like?
- He looked like a guy.
- Woah.
- He kind of looked like you.
- [Zach] Was that you from the future?
Did you come back to spy on me as a kid?
- Maybe.
(laughing)